bevor wir hier eine Studie und
zahlenschlacht machen kommen wir zu
ihrer These sonst rennt die Zeit weg sie
es passt ja sehr sehr gut weil sie
fordern ja heute was was die ich finde
das Wort ungeimpft so beschissen
deswegen was die Menschen die sich gegen
eine corona-impfung entschieden haben da
wollen sie heute darüber reden über die
einrichtungsbezogene Flächen das ist
tatsächlich so tatsächlich das mal
erwähnen in Hamburg sind 250
Betretungsverbote ausgesprochen worden
zum Gesundheitspersonal in den Kliniken
und in den Pflegeheimen und ich muss
Ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen nachdem ich die
Zahlen untersucht habe zur Bundeswehr
zum Uniklinikum Würzburg zur Uniklinik
zur in Eppendorf in Hamburg eines der
großen Unikliniken einer der großen
Unikliniken muss ich leider feststellen
dass eine Behauptung es würde dadurch
den Patienten weniger Risiko
entgegengebracht wenn nur noch geimpfte
an sie herankommen das ist komplett
falsch und sogar es ist sogar das
Gegenteil der Fall also wir stellen
aufgrund der Daten und Zahlen fest dass
seit die dritte Impfung gegeben wird wir
tatsächlich eine erhöhte Inzidenz bei
den Geimpften vorfinden also bei starken
Gruppen die jetzt geschlossen sind
Uniklinikum Eppendorf 99% Impfquote
Bundeswehr bis zu 97 Uniklinikum
Würzburg auch weit über die 90 Prozent
und alle Gruppen die weniger geimpft
sind sind tatsächlich weniger von Corona
betroffen wir sehen das in den
Intensivstationen wir haben nur nach
11,4 Prozent da sind die umgeimpften
ungeimpfte und wir stellen fest dass
sogar vierfach geimpfte tatsächlich auf
den Intensivstationen liegen und jetzt
kommt noch der schlimmste Teil wir haben
jetzt schon das erste Bundesland das ist
leider Herr dohrendorf ihr Bundesland
Niedersachsen wo wir mehr 80-Jährige die
an- und mit Corona gestorben sind
gegenüber 2021 und 2020 also die Impfung
wird unsere uns nicht aus der ganzen
Lage raus katapultieren aber die
Betretungsverbote sind natürlich eine
personalverengende Maßnahme die die
Kliniken in noch mehr Schwierigkeiten
bringt jeder wird gebraucht da fallen
die Leute aus in den Kliniken ohne
verwendet und trotzdem müssen ja die und
trotzdem werden Leute nach Hause
geschickt das ist ein unmöglicher
Zustand die Leute kriegen gar keinen
Ausgleich die entlassen werden die
werden bedroht mit schreiben sie müssen
sich impfen lassen und so weiter also
ein unhaltbarer Zustand und das gleiche
ist übrigens bei der Bundeswehr und wenn
wir sehen dass die Impfung gar nichts
bringt auch nicht so aufrecht Erhaltung
der Truppe dann kann ich Ihnen nur sagen
wenn sie solche Daten nicht ansehen dann
gehören sie auch nicht in irgendwelche
Expertenteams hinein das tut mir leid
dass ich ihnen das so sagen muss sie
müssen sich die Daten angucken Schulden
ich wusste nicht dass ich heute hier im
Expertenteam sitze
eine eine
Frage die mich wirklich beschäftigt wenn
man ihrer These zuhört dann sagen sie ja
eigentlich unterbrechen Sie mich gerne
wenn ich sie falsch wieder gebe dann
sagen Sie eigentlich dass schwere
Verläufe durch die Impfung nicht
verhindert werden können weil das ist ja
das Argument für die Impfung ganz klar
deswegen sich viele Menschen impfen
lassen über 60 über 70 über 80 auch
Menschen mit Vorerkrankungen würden sie
also die Impfung schon differenziert
sehen oder sagen Sie ganz klar keine
corona-impfung also ich sage ganz klar
keine corona-impfung und ich sage auch
es gibt natürlich eine zweite
Möglichkeit wie das alles zu
interpretieren ist wir sammeln ja seit
drei Jahren und man muss ja sagen wir
brauchen keine Studien mehr wir haben
die Wirklichkeit als zahlen da ich habe
krankenkassendaten untersucht ich kann
ganz viele Sachen über die
Impfnebenwirkungen sagen ich kann über
die Zustände gehen können nicht beweisen
dass der schwere Verlauf nicht durch die
Corona Impfung verhindert wird die
Zahlen des RKI anzuschauen und dann
sehen sie dass die Leute die jetzt mit
Corona
positivtest dass da komme ich jetzt
gleich zu dass die Leute die dort liegen
zu einem kleineren Teil als proportional
geimpft wurde
ungeimpft in den Kliniken in den
Intensivstationen liegen während die
geimpften zu einem größeren Teil dort
liegen jetzt komme ich zu dem wichtigen
Teil
Menschen nicht also geimpft als nicht
geimpft das habe ich alles dazu einen
berechnet und wenn Sie das in Proportion
zueinander setzen dann sind die
ungeimpften
unterproportional repräsentiert in den
Intensivstationen und deswegen können
sie davon ausgehen und wir haben auch
noch übrigens noch nie so viele über
80-jährige mit Corona in den
Krankenhäusern gehabt wie jetzt in den
letzten Wochen also in den gesamten
weltweit also
zahlen können sie ja gar nicht sagen
aber ich weiß von die Intensivstationen
von den Kollegen die da arbeiten ja sie
kommt natürlich ein paar darf ich
demnächst mal ausreden ja dass die
Patienten die da liegen
multimodapnorbide sind also mehrere
Erkrankungen haben und gerade die der
Coronavirus am meisten trifft und nicht
dass man durch die Impfung Corona krank
wird also diese Behauptung möchte ich
gerne widerlegen weil da gibt's genügend
Zeit zu erleben das sind doch die Zahlen
ja dass sie das so behaupten möchte ich
gerne die Zahlen können sie sich
angucken das ist keine behaupten ich
kenne die Zahl nur nicht die sie so
interpretieren wie sie gerne sehen ich
sehe normale Neuköllner Bürger in der
Praxis und die sind deutlich weniger
krank wenn sie geimpft sind als wenn sie
nicht geimpft sind und vor allen Dingen
auch wenn Sie mit dem neuen Impfstoff
der schon kombiniert ist geimpft sind
kriegen sie auch weniger Omega das ist
das was ich sehe wir öffnen Sie bei der
Frau Gaschke was ich jetzt ganz stark
das Gefühl habe ich weiß nicht geht
haben wir vielleicht einfach zu wenig
Daten dass man einfach jetzt ganz klar
das schon sehen kann wer jetzt hier im
Recht ist oder nicht bei diesem Battle
ich glaube nicht dass wir zu wenig Daten
haben aber ich glaube dass wir sie
überhaupt nicht vernünftig aufbereitet
haben also ich glaube die
Expertenkommission zu Corona hat das ja
irgendwie versucht aber ist da an
einigen Stellen erstaunlich auch wenig
in die Tiefe gegangen und dann hat man
noch nicht auf sie gehört und dieses
hier müsste man jetzt in der Tat so
sehen da sind ja da kommen natürlich zu
dem was sie sagen Faktoren dazu das ist
schon richtig also wird irgendwo mehr
getestet sozusagen ist die neuere
Variante ansteckender und deswegen so
überspring
also hätte ich schon noch fragen woher
kommt's nicht was dann müsste man ja als
Journalist fragen was macht die Impfung
mit dem Körper so dass er anfälliger
wird dann wäre es natürlich komplett
irre wenn es so wäre dann müsste man
aufhören Journalisten werden morgen mit
ihren Fakten Prüfern werden sie auch
nicht losgehen da bin ich das bin ich ja
auch schon gewohnt ich habe ja auch
schon Prozesse gegen die Tagesschau
geführt und so weiter also all diese
Sachen muss man sich ja anhören wenn man
nur die Zahlen eigentlich nur sagt jetzt
habe ich dazu eben zu Ende sagen darf
und ich finde aber den den Umgang mit
den Zahlen ganz ganz skandalös also
jetzt haben wir das ja seit zweieinhalb
Jahren seit fast drei Jahren das Problem
und ich finde so auch sowas zu sagen
also die die STIKO ist ja ehrenamtlich
und und das ist ja sicher auch aller
ehrenwert ja verdammt noch mal warum ist
die denn nach drei Monate drei Jahren
immer noch ehrenamtlich also wenn wir
jetzt ein großes Problem haben dass die
Gesellschaft im Milliarden gekostet hat
das Kinder sozusagen ihre Jugend
gekostet hat dass also demokratische
Prozesse extrem in Frage gestellt hat
dann kann ich doch wohl so eine
Kommission aufstocken dann also nicht
warum ist das RKI also immer noch nicht
in der Lage bestimmte Zahlen die
vorliegen zu interpretieren weil man
offensichtlich Interesse daran hat
Zahlen noch nicht hat also die Zahl sind
alle da also da kommen Sie mir nicht mit
Zahlen